los peces ya no abundan en el lago
izabal desde que comenzó la actividad de
la mina fénix en 2014 los pescadores de
la zona denuncian la grave contaminación
de sus aguas que a la larga nos trae
muerte
porque no estaba modelada lo que está
haciendo el lugar se está convirtiendo
en un desierto ya lo mencioné nosotros
dependemos del nacimiento de los de los
de las fuentes de agua en el pueblo
guatemalteco el estor las protestas en
contra de la minera propiedad de
guatemala níquel co subsidiaria del
grupo inversionistas suizos old way no
cesan las de este fin de semana se
tornaron violentas por lo que el
gobierno decretó el estado de sitio
desde el domingo y llenó la ciudad de
más de mil militares decisión que ha
sido calificada como una criminalización
de la lucha de los manifestantes que
denuncian que la empresa sigue operando
aún a pesar de que el año pasado un
tribunal del país ordenó suspender sus
actividades una orden que la empresa no
está dispuesta a respetar
el tema de cerrar nuestras operaciones
simplemente no está sobre la mesa porque
no hay razones para ello el conflicto
entre la conservación ambiental y el
impulso económico entre los defensores
del agua y los promotores del empleo
generado por la mina han acabado por
distanciar a los habitantes de la zona
el otro grupo que les llaman
prominero verdad que solo ven que hay
dinero ahora un conflicto que no parece
encontrar una cercana resolución el
gobierno de guatemala publicó un
comunicado en el que afirmaba que la
orden judicial que reclama la comunidad
no aplica para la minera